so essentially I work at the University
of Chicago I'm originally from Charlotte
to Virginia so I'm always happy to be
come back to the East Coast
I lead a weekly our spatial workshop
there so I teach researchers how to use
spatial data and this talk is
essentially cribbed from that um every
time I teach that every week I teach
that researchers come up to me and
they're like yeah you look you showed me
how to make these cool Maps and like do
these analyses in art how do I get the
spatial data like what is spatial data
like what's a shape file like can you
help me with that
and so I decided to sort of take a step
back and instead of telling you about my
cool spatial autocorrelation and
regressions and things that I loved I
wanted to take a step back and think
about the step before that so how do you
get spatial data what is spatial data
how many people here have worked with
spatial data okay so a lot of people
have so maybe this is maybe too
elementary for you how many people feel
like they have a good grasp of what
spatial data is yeah so hopefully
today's talk will clarify a little bit
of that talk a bit through some of the
tips that I find helpful maybe walk
through a few tools that I use as well
this is good I just get like extra
minutes to talk at you
great awesome so um spatial data a
little bit about me I wanted to talk a
bit about the communities I'm a part of
I'm the only reason I'm on the stage is
because of the amazingness of our
community and if you want to be on this
stage you should be on it because you're
part of our community and you're valued
and you're awesome so um let's see about
me this is me um teaching my workshop at
the Center for spatial data science at
the University of Chicago I have to do
research half like help people with
their own research last year I was just
helping people with their own research
and that drove me a little bit crazy so
I was like put me on a project so you
can fee up here I'm teaching people how
to make a choropleth map I'm helping
people debug their spatial installations
and I believe back here I'm like
presenting a little bit of my own
research um I'm also a part of the Our
Lady's community
I run the Our Lady Chicago group um you
should if you're in the area you should
go to the Our Lady's DC group which is
run by Kelly and
going back in the corner or if you're in
Charles Ville or other parts I think Sam
is outside so she runs our Lady
Charlotte's little group I have found
this community to be super welcoming and
just really helping me along in my
learning journey we do hackathons
together we have talks you know we talk
about cool things we've learned and are
together and and for me it's been a
really good way to force myself to learn
things about getting up in front of a
stage and practicing talking about shiny
or maps or the tiny purse okay um
carpentry is instructor I recently
joined this community and so the carbon
trees is a community that encourages our
researchers to become better at their
computational ability and the idea being
that when you're in grad school people
just sort of expect you to know are all
of a sudden like I don't know when that
happened like they sort of you're like
yeah you know get you know she'll you
know are you know Python etc go do your
analysis and it's like where do people
learn that and so part of the Carpenters
community is teaching people how to do
that so if you're interested I have
carpentry stickers as well I don't know
if they're any carpentry as instructors
in here as anyone in the carpentry
instructor okay they're like a few in
here maybe one um you can also by the
way if you are at an academic or
nonprofit or I think probably even
governmental institution you can request
Parpan Tory's instructors to come do
workshops for you at your institution
and we're volunteers so um anyway and
there are a few other things when I'm
not thinking about spatial data our
communities and open-source
I play Ultimate Frisbee big fan of that
I don't know if anyone here play
Ultimate Frisbee and I I love biking as
well so this is me biking around I think
in Mexico City so um okay previously I
gave a talk last year I naively thought
this would be the last time I would ever
give a spatial talk at DCR so I called
it bitly DC spatial um but we're back
for more bit late DC spacial 2019 so I
guess I'll just keep naming it the year
or someone else can take on the spatial
talk for next year and you I'll give you
permission to use the 2021 um last
year's talk was a bit more about a
specific use case I pulled some crime
data from the DC open data portal you
can go to that link and check it out if
you're interested
this time I'm going to talk a bit more
about one step before that how do I get
started with spatial analysis in our and
so this is you know where do I get that
data what tools do I use it's like what
can I even do what does that mean I'm
going to break this down into three
parts first where do I start second what
tools do you use and three exciting part
where there lots of maps and things what
can I do um so first where do I start um
so this meme right here you could
replace this with a really ugly
spreadsheet and a beautiful ggplot2
visualization and if you get the same
idea right so most people when they
think of spatial data they think of
beautiful maps amazing visualizations
cool stuff what Alex showed you
yesterday I'm here to tell you that
unfortunately there's a step before that
so this is right here it's sort of what
a Geo JSON looks like in real life and
then you see this and you're like oh no
how do I get from that to that math that
I want to see um I actually don't
believe the whole thing here I believe
everyone deserves a look at a beautiful
map everyone deserves to have awesome
visualizations and but I want to sort of
talk about that data stuff before so
it's gonna be really boring for like
maybe five minutes but I'm gonna try to
make interesting the two main types of
spatial data and there's vector data and
raster data so how are these two things
different vector data is points lines
and polygons and raster data are grid
pixels and cells and so I'm gonna mainly
be talking about vector data because in
the social sciences I have a background
in economics this is what we mainly work
with we look at you know where our firms
located where our county borders you
know what our road networks looking like
grids pixels themselves you can imagine
satellite imagery so when satellites fly
out and they take pictures of like how
land is used
you know like oceanography folks in sort
of environmental sciences use a ton of
that um not really spatial data
controversial addresses zip codes
counties why isn't this really spatial
data well it sort of is its spatial data
to humans right so we know addresses
we can use zip codes to figure out you
know where is my favorite restaurant
down the block we couldn't use this to
navigate through the world however if
you were going to be working with
computers and if you'd be using are to
do spatial data you need a way for
addresses zip codes counties to become
interpreted by computers and that's
going to be taking the form of you know
coordinates points lines polygons and
all of that so this is sort of a hard
thing to grasp and a lot of people I
work with have trouble grasping this
which is why I get a lot of Excel
spreadsheets that say hey here's a list
of emergency departments like make a map
write like analyze like where things are
so I'm right here this is me reading in
with read excel of this excel
spreadsheet I got assigning it to this
variable called ers
by the way if you didn't know if you put
parentheses around variable assignment
you'll get a print as well so that's
pretty cool um so this is what the data
looks like I'm like yes emergency
departments and I'm like no it's not
really spatial data right so I have
Hospital names I have the location which
is the city and the state in Illinois
and I have this like mysterious region
whatever that means now um in order to
make this into spatial data that I can
work with I can't just have the city and
state and region if I had outlines of
the regions maybe I could like start
doing a join doing things like that
let's say I just want to plot where
these hospitals are in Illinois so not
good
we're gonna do a thing called geocoding
and this is the step that like a lot of
people don't realize that they have to
do what is geocoding by the way thank
you to Georgetown University for hosting
us this is an awesome auditorium so
shout out I used you all in this example
and so what you do is essentially take
text input say an address or something
and what you're gonna do is throw it
into a function say geocode OS m which
means use the OpenStreetMap api to do a
geo code and then i'm going to throw in
this address and then get coordinates
out the coordinates are really what i
need so you can see that I get X Y and
then the third thing right there the B
box is like the square around that
feature so imagine it's sort of like the
edge of like
the outline of your mat right um so you
may also notice that we have X Y this is
hard for people it's not latitude
longitude its longitude and latitude
every time I think about this I have to
be like latitude longitude no the other
way
like longitude so I've done this before
and made maps that are like completely
wrong so I see some nods and the
audience's you may have encountered this
okay so do you coded it I have a picnic
slide talking about some ways that you
could geo code I have access to the
University of Chicago geo coder which is
awesome if you're at an institution this
is probably the best way to geocode
things in bulk otherwise if you're sort
of doing it for fun you can use there's
a slide in the appendix sort of talking
about how to do this let's say go ahead
and geo code there's a CSV here and this
is much better
so you can see here and when I do code
it I get an ID column sort of just to do
that on I get the address and I get I
split it up using separate into city and
state um and I get a latitude longitude
and latitude I always get it wrong and I
also get a match score which tells me
you know how close is this likely to
actually be where it is so um talk to
your GIS librarian or I talked to your
GIS expert or talk to someone who has a
license of ArcGIS and they can do this
for you or you can do it yourself
so alright cool that's in a map yay so
this is essentially how you go from that
Excel spreadsheet that someone just
tossed that you are like ah make a map
and you are going to go ahead and do
this process and convert it to this
there are few intermediate steps here
before you get into a map but I'm here
to talk to you about like the part that
no understands about spatial data
spatial data formats are confusing so
the most common spatial data formats are
the following shapefiles goj Suns geo
packages CS knees tips there's so many
more out there there wasn't really a
standard before and like everyone sort
of came up with their own spatial data
format these are the five that I use the
most often you'll see shape files a lot
shape files are sort of the file format
that was pioneered by ESRI which is the
the company that makes ArcGIS and it's
to become prevalent unfortunately for
you state files are actually for files
because there for some reason it was
like impossible to like store geospatial
data can be really large because you
have all these massive polygons and
things and so they decided to sort into
four files so you need all four and your
directory in order for it to work that's
why I sort of prefer geo JSON this is
more common if you're doing blood
mapping if you're working with Deb's and
they want to make a map geo day Suns are
sort of what they're probably gonna use
to create those maps and things online
and apps I really like I've started
moving to geo packages they're awesome
they're one thing they don't cut off
your variable names shape files cut your
variable names off at seven characters
which is very annoying when you write
them and CSVs as you can as you could
saw before I usually get CSVs with like
latitude and latitude on them so I just
use them as geospatial data and finally
tips when you're dealing with raster
data many more there are so many spatial
data things these are all read by GL
which is the geographic data abstraction
library okay so if you look at these all
day alright so use these file types in
our I have started moving to a library
called SS because it reads all of these
file types in without me having to worry
about it
I you do library SF and then I use st
read you know yars dot shape file
alternatively if you prefer tidy tidy
data AKA you don't want your files read
in with spring strings as factors i like
read SF so this is another way to sort
of do that creates a tidy SF data frame
so it looks a little bit similar to your
sort of normal tittle there's a little
summary at the top with some spatial
information the most important thing is
it is a normal table but it has this
geometry column right here
so each geometry okay each shape is
stored as a series of like coordinates
and things and it's in that last column
called geometry this makes it so that
you couldn't use the tidy verse and use
those tools with spatial things like
this and which is nice because for me it
means going from normal analysis where
I'm just creating you know with working
with data tables that are not spatial I
can use the same tools when I'm working
with my spatial workflow and that is
like you
because before this spate like working
with spatial data has been like can be a
hassle it can be like you have this
change it into like this list column and
then doing a lot of things that way so
um this is what I prefer for that okay
this may be the most important slight
slide on here and when I wrote it I was
like why didn't I share this with anyone
before how do you Google search for
spatial data how do you find spatial
data these are the key words I would use
to find spatial data so park district
boundaries food vendor shape file
administrative district polygons road
network geometries abandoned car GIS
files um remember addresses zip codes
and regions are not spatial data and
they can't be interpreted by computers
so what you're gonna look for are these
like geo things right polygons
boundaries lines and so for example if I
search DC boundary shapefile geospatial
shapefile geo JSON just all of it just
to be careful I get this nice DC
boundary remember remembering how to
Google what to Google is how you get
anything done so um if you want to take
a photo of this I think this is possibly
I want to just share it out because I
think it's the most important slide I've
ever made in my life so good okay um so
then you get the first three sort of
options are from the open data DC portal
and so I highly recommend you know
sometimes just knowing what to search is
like the door that unlocks everything
right so okay so to what tool should I
use and I'm definitely gonna run out of
time so my toolkit is do you have a QGIS
ArcGIS post yes cardo and are given that
this is an R conference we're gonna talk
about the the last one but like most of
us I'm not necessarily a single youth
like a single for my geospatial analysis
I don't used to use one thing there are
many our packages out there for spatial
data does anyone know what this is and
anyone want to guess what this is
has anyone gone to this page or like
know what this is at all okay um this is
what is known as the cran task view so
if you go to like the actual cran
website which is where you get your our
packages from there are a sin
like groups of packages just listed by
topic and in this there's a spatial one
and when you go to the spatial task of
you this is what that looks like and you
go all the way down you're like okay
cool all these packages okay there are a
lot of packages okay cool I'm going down
I'm going down let me see you what
packages there and then you get to this
list nice
um so I'm here to tell you that there
are a lot of packages for everything in
our and you may not want to sort through
this so I'm going to talk to you a bit
about what my workflow looks like this
is what I mainly use right now
disclaimer I am sort of on the like I
have the time because I work at a
university to sort of think through like
what tools I want to use and sort of
what I can choose right like if you have
workflows that use other things it's
okay
so this is sort of what I sort of see is
the cutting edge of spatial right now um
similar packages to these I like my
teddy bursts and stuff and I like
working it with it with spatial data and
the reason that it's similar that each
of these are similar are the first one I
would say SF allows you to ingest
spatial data clean it and manipulate it
in a tidy way the second I would say
team app um I do use ggplot2 for some of
my maps but team app I'll show you later
has like a really cool functionality
where I can go between interactive and
static maps um
SP DEP is because I work in like spatial
kind of metrics and things like that
that's my modeling package you can think
of it sort of like the glim net you
don't use it every day it's like not
that like you know so sometimes you need
it and then SP it's like data table non
tidy yet useful in certain specialized
cases and a lot of old packages sort of
depend on SP so the analogies not quite
there but we'll go with it okay what can
I do
here's the exciting part I wanted to
talk a little bit about the most recent
I think it's like actually the the tidy
Tuesday two things ago they had some
data about the squirrel census in New
York City so the the the the data set
was essentially they sent out these like
volunteers to like go count squirrels in
Central Park and then they like
recording where they saw each of them
and I was like yes finally a spatial
data set for tiny Tuesday um so I was
really excited about that and I decided
to like do some analysis so I actually
cheated a little bit
I'm like New York park boundaries area
so I think they like figured out a way
to classify different parts of the park
depending on something and then I pulled
into Team app one nice thing about team
app is I went ahead and did like a
population count of squirrels by area in
the park you can see that there's one
area that's a little bit darker I'm like
why are there so many squirrels in that
area are there so many vendors and so
what happened was I decided to change
the mode and go ahead and do an
interactive view and so I could zoom in
and out of that right so I ran one line
of code team app mode view and then I
ran the same code again let's see it
again
so I'm running my code I'm creating a
static map I get this count by area and
then I've changed the mode right so I'm
changing the mode I run the same code
again and I get this interactive map and
so it can switch between static mapping
and interactive like interactive
exploration like that that for me is
super valuable because I want to know
the context in which I'm creating the
spatial data so you know then I actually
took a look and I think that that red
part right there it's known as the
ramble which I don't know if there are
people here and I guess it's like a
woodsy part of the area I thought maybe
they were just like a lot of like hot
dog vendors and I was like what if I
could hold it like the hot dog vendors
and stuff but they don't have I don't
know if they have data on that so anyway
um so this is one nice thing that you
could now do in our right so you're
changing your look like running one line
of code and then you're running the same
visualization code again
by the way a team app the idea the
syntax is similar to Judy plot
it's just plusses and you're adding
layers on top so that's pretty cool
so I'm alternating between interactive
exploration and static mapping um check
out Matthew also for a GIS like
experience so if you are familiar with
GIS and GIS tools and you sort of want
to replicate that and our map views
awesome it allows you to hover on things
and sort of pop up ID tables also reishi
ater for 3d visualization and graphics I
have like the fortune of like going
being the last facial toss so I was like
I'll just like mention some of these
packages that you could use okay last
thing I want to sort of REM beside think
beyond dots on a map so this book how to
live with maps I think they're really
useful as sort of a visualization
understanding basic things for up for me
and
- enter that's sort of like the first
level right exploratory spatial data
analysis you're creating these
visualizations what else can you do
beyond that
why does where matter why does like
where something happens matter because
like for example does the house price in
this area of your city does it affect
house prices around it you know does the
location of you know pharmacies for I
don't know for certain like for certain
populations is it clustered like are
there certain places where their guests
and so this is important because Tobi's
first law of geography says everything
is relating to everything else but near
things aren't more related than distant
things and so when you start thinking in
this way when you start being a spatial
thinker you're gonna consider you know
what sort of like why are things close
to each other why they more similar is
that a symptom of you know is that
spatial autocorrelation is does that
mean that there patterns in the data so
this is using geo des and ru to detect
spatial patterns so I think it was
Milwaukee right now or it was like
Milwaukee a few years ago
we essentially had the real map on the
right which is the percentage of
african-american I think by capita and
then we just used we just sort of like
randomly scattered like the values
across the map when you look at a
histogram of this data they look exactly
the same right so what we've done is
taken the attributes across areas and we
just distributed those attributes across
any area so when you look at the history
rooms really Co like you know the
percent like percent african-american is
like you know similar but when you look
at things like Moran's I scatter plots
you'll see that you can detect spatial
patterns and that's really really
important so something else that you can
do is look at local spatial
autocorrelation so our points are values
in an area are they related to each
other our values like are they does are
they more likely to be related to each
other or are they likely to be distinct
from each other is there some
relationship there and finally you may
have done clustering normal clustering
I'm spatially constrained clustering um
what happens if you decide to limit your
clusters only to things that are next to
you
does that matter does that change the
output of what you have and so with that
and I wanted to mention that we have a
pre-alpha release of our G Oda right up
now so a lot of this interesting spatial
analysis you can do in our and there's
certain functionalities missing if you
want to test this out I think there's
still a lot of work to be done but you
can sort of see what type of what types
of functionalities are in there and I've
definitely gone over time so if you want
to stay in touch I will be I'm always on
Twitter and I will be teeing the modern
geospatial analysis tutorial at our
studio comm and leaving the geospatial
track at use our so please submit
tutorials there and there's some my
contacts so thank you so much
[Applause]